[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
we might be alive I don't know
hi Emma I knew that was gonna happen to
give me the 10-second countdown you
didn't give me the rest
hey Wyatt welcome to another day of
games what play for all charity streams
professionals here as always I'm very
excited today because I'm joined by Jake
Baldy now thank you so much from Gabe
rags but joy because you were on a
couple weeks ago to do the game case
trivia with min Max and all those lovely
folks and that was such a close game
that was unreal one sec so I'll produce
it in the chat is saying that your mic
is doubling and we're not sure why yeah
wait let me try say something now how
about now still doubling it's coming
through the game but we couldn't figure
out how to make that not happen so we
are playing portal 2 in coop and there
is no way to turn it off it says it's on
push-to-talk
[Music]
just saw me throw her out okay
port a he is he's coping with this from
the from the production side so while
he's figuring that out um let me talk a
little bit about what we're doing here
today so we're playing portal 2 but
we're also raising money for charity
there are two links on screen right now
so we are raising money for two causes
black lives matter so if you go to
Victor ly / GS - BLM you could donate
for that fantastic cause and another
charity that we're raising money for is
Kovan relief so we're working directly
with Direct Relief who are providing
healthcare frontline healthcare workers
with essential protection protective
clothing and such and support so if
you'd like to donate to that cause link
is on screen now bit on ly / GS - kovat
tey how are we feeling about the mic
situation is that all sorted he says he
he says I think it'll be okay Jake I run
out I'm still getting it no all right
hang out I don't know hey I'm trying
everything thing I don't know what it
could be though cuz I'm getting it back
twice but I don't know if the stream is
getting it back twice
okay
hmm
[Music]
whichever let's what do you guys think I
mean you guys are let's go for my
sounding Jake I say I don't think we
really need game audion that much take
it one sec I think I too may have fixed
oh I tried something different here
shout out the windows
do I sound any better mm-hmm still
getting it then I got nothing so this
was working perfectly and then we went
live and it didn't work
Oh No
okay I'm fine with I'm fine with that if
you guys want to do that Oh chat sucks
it's sounding better than it did ah okay
ah I say okay well shout out to portal I
guess I don't understand I don't need to
hear too many game anyway to turn off
mic one thing that's always bothered me
how it takes precedence there is no
solution what the hell also with an
actual thing oh you have to type in the
games console wow you have to type in
the games console okay how do I get that
up portal to gaming console Lister
console commands escape options Oh
cancel I think I hit the red one options
keyboard mouse allow developer console
and then press the tilde key oh my god
we're hacking voice underscore mute I'm
the host
so should you do it or should I don't I
think I could do it okay okay try that
now testing hello oh my god what is it
yeah yeah alright
whoa okay
oh okay I guess laughs wedding now jeez
oh my god sue said good time I found
back Oh cuz I'm not lying - okay let's
start this over Jake thank you so much
for joining us we did it
we've hacked portal I feel this is the
closest I will ever become to being some
kind of scientist
we picked Paul - because it's a nice fun
that co-op game to play we have everyone
in the chat who are cheering us on us hi
chat if you have questions for Jake
please throw them in that please if
you're watching donate to the two
coolest is that are on the screen right
now should we get into the game which we
do it yes also I think I should I should
tell chat feel free to give us some
guidance I think maybe we both play
without having any guides up we both
haven't played this since it released
I'm guessing so yeah so when I was
looking this up I saw on my Steam that
the last time I played this was when the
game first came out so okay good so
we're in the same exact boat oh and also
I am like kind of terrible with mouse
and keyboard I used to play a lot of
overwatch on mouse and keyboard but then
I kind of became a console player
because that's where all my friends went
to so see how this one goes this will be
just fine this will be great with two
elite gamers let's do this I'm gonna
gesture you hello I'm gonna do the robot
I actually don't I can't figure out how
to do it really so I hit you hit Q and
then why and then it's a circle so that
just came to a big one hold it hold it
down yeah it's not
uzuki is my game broken are you serious
is it a selectable we like ease like you
scroll at the mass through the wheel you
should just like be able to if you hold
down Q and then there's like a wheel
yeah yeah I won't let me do anything
Oh your controller plugged in yeah oh
there we go
you know something you pointed at
something there we go this is already
already just cute oh I'd request got any
chat Oh use my ping and your Wescott in
the chat suggests that we pick some
portal like the community maps so let's
do that let's get used to the game yeah
let's see I don't even know what any of
these are I am NOT smart thinking sure
yeah it's meant to take it everyday it's
meant to be good for your close enough I
mean we passed the first puzzle we
should think of some donation incentives
I'll throw a dollar to each one to each
cause forever for every test chamber
that we managed to pass I what work
actually does match it so we're gonna -
portals ping oh my god I need to turn
that down
that is a very sensitive Mouse
thinking back to know what should you go
I just I just killed myself we ride
together we die together exactly thank
you
respect okay all right
it's very wait I haven't done like mouse
keep what stuff for so long
oh okay do you have to go there so you
have to point on a pool surface yeah
yeah and then I do the same huh and then
what like up there - ah there we go
I did it and then I can't believe how
like unfamiliar I am it's pretty bad
it's wild and I feel like in 20 like
when was Paul the first time 2007 this
game first came out and then the sequel
I was so obsessed with it I was so good
at it and then I don't know what
happened
I just haven't touched it in absolutely
yes thank you let me learning look at
this look at this look I can even
guessed her now
hey it only took me four minutes yeah I
love what you
speed runs at 400 yeah yeah
do you watch what's is it your favorite
game to watch speedrun something like
old games like Mario games and stuff I
think that's oh wait what do i do do i
where's the other oh you can you put one
here just overwrite mine oh this is
gonna be hard okay we got pings figured
out
we've got gestures figured out yeah
we're getting there okay so this is how
you make a ping all down know someone in
the chat says a $1 for every portal shot
oh my god oh wait let me go sir tomorrow
saying in the chat this last day you see
Mario instead of Mario oh boy
yes no no you're among friends here I'm
British it's Mario
it is Mario thank you uh England in New
York where in the state we're on the
same page and I guess the app for it
there's so much I don't know closer in
distance maybe I don't know it's kind of
in the middle oh thank you throw this
yeah I actually I kind of adapted my
it's the exact thing you're not supposed
to do as a content creator change who
you are but and be not authentic but
I've tried to change the way I say Mario
I say Mario in videos because people get
so mad no I just don't I don't want to
hear it anymore I I think can you can
you go down there um I say betta instead
of beta but I know I make it think of it
I just I just kind of say I'm not saying
I'm not saying beta Oh
be true to yourself that's something I
should do okay I'm through oh wait and
so then I'll put a boil here and one
yeah oh yeah and then you can get on
this and then I can face sorry good wait
can we dance or something oh you can
play your rock-paper-scissors this is
just like army of two oh my god favorite
card game the devil's hotel level cartel
and the sixth day or something like that
even though I think that's an arm in the
chat someone says a dollar for every
grain of salt to be taken okay that's my
that's my phrase that's my reporting and
use phrase I like it
oh is this the right one for me my
orange I don't know who I am
I think I'm Orange oh yeah you are cuz
it's you my god is awesome thank you
everyone
before joining us I'm gonna be keeping
an eye on donations and messages in the
chat so please throw all your questions
and throw your money to the two great
causes that we're raising money for okay
so I've done I think we have a couple
that we didn't get round to yesterday so
what what was the day yesterday the 17th
I don't okay so I don't please you
shouldn't send you outside of the
official test I'm trying to read some
donations here she's got so much sass
I'm gonna turn it down a little bit I'm
sorry that's okay so donations thank you
so much for everyone who's sending money
to these two fantastic causes for black
lives matter we got $20 from Alexander
Esme Lee thank you so much Laura Baldy
no $25 thank you that's my job
oh that's so sweet hi Bradley Deni $10
for black guys Martin
nice Jake and Amanda Baldino
got $100 thank you so much for code
relief and Alexander is as Meili has
also given $20 to direct really cute so
thank you so much thank you everyone
links on screen if you like to donate if
you're unable to donate please there are
so many good resources to share around
black guys matter and for direct relief
so please try to your part share those
share the stream if you'd like if you'd
like to get other people involved who
you think can donate or just hang out
and have a good time with us cuz I'm
very excited to bloody place in Paul to
Jake all right oh wow they have step
counter why do I have so many more steps
than you there's a snow current up here
oh it oh it was a step counter second
ago but this I don't think this is true
no I don't know why place nominee
alright yeah no way
all right let's see link is this a glad
I'll strike is she just lying to us I
feel like she's just lying to us I
missed this stuff this like old valve
world building and storytelling that's
why I liked Alex so much because it was
like oh my god I remember this it's so
good I never played it so I am genuinely
a little bit worried about this because
I get really bad motion sickness okay
and valve games are kind of notorious
for that at least with me oh please
select a level then proceed to Wichita
Oh have we done all these I think we
don't I guess ok let's do 6 yeah ok
check can you keep an eye on how many we
have completed please so I think that
count as one big one the tutorial one I
guess I may be from now cuz these ones
should be like the actual
levels okay um so you enjoyed Alex yeah
you should still give it a shot because
it's definitely like pretty for like in
intense VR people because there is a lot
of moving and going on and you
traditionally you kind of play it like a
straight-up first-person shooter in VR
but valve has a lot of options they did
a really good job kind of giving you so
many different options and ways to tweak
and sliders on how you want to move how
fast it is how sensitive it is so it
might it might accommodate you
that's what I've been telling people
it's like the fact that the options are
there is good yeah oh wait down here hmm
oh wait can I get in there yes okay oh
wow look at that look Hey
oh where is the disk security through
obscurity isn't this game also still
looks pretty damn good yeah this would
just like Oh
sauce like it but I think it's because
it's so really well stylized and
realized like it has a very I don't know
like it's so immediately identifiable
well can I hit that
okay what did that do that was maybe
sorry there's no waving
uh maybe the other side Oh mmm Chatham I
need you to help us out yeah keep keep
your pace going okay we can't go back so
there's nothing to so you can't put
oneness on this side Raman no broth says
I wonder if there's a way to slowly
acclimate yourself to via if you have
motion sickness problem I don't think
enough VR games have the wealth of
settings that Alex does definitely not
um
[Music]
I have issues with specific games so oh
oh the switch is operable Oh maybe at
the same time okay ready okay so three
two one one did work okay oh oh hang on
hang on
so we have to place a portal okay okay
so I'll I'll get ready so if we hit it
again three we're shooting the portal
you or me I'll shoot it okay ready wait
also can we clarify something I'm sorry
uh-huh three two one hit it or like
three two one hit or like three two one
zero
hit like everybody does it that's all
that's good let's go three two one go
and go and go three two one go got it
okay ready yeah
three two one go
okay so now Hey go we're in Vice
brilliant okay look at us there's and
there's we I haven't time to I
clobbering the coffee cup okay alright
this is so there we go perfect I feel
like a genius
I feel oh just as you said that he felt
like a genius great of her to assume
that Oh
was that you or was that both of us were
loaded Mohammed Amin says Jake's please
say pizza is on me no I'll say it pizzas
on me that's how I am that's how I end
our Friday show I owe a lot of people a
lot of pizza
to be fair though you're in New York
you'll have the best I have I have a
plethora I have
surplus of pizza okay so did not shut
down New York shut down but pizza just
kept going
look pizzas not gonna okay do we try it
no I haven't been to New York
oh is it I can't get out okay yeah well
let me go past 6:00 and we just did six
that's wait oh wait can we go to chuck
Oh
welcome to counting with Jacob Lucy oh
yeah yeah yeah so here I got you oh no
sorry I owe the rope you go again
I want to do it okay
oh never that doesn't fit that I forgot
about that level so do you just do eight
yeah I missed the I've totally like
mystile the level flow so we did seven
because we just did six yeah perfect
look at us
so how many more weeks technically are
you guys doing this for hmm so this is
our third week we're running for another
three nice which is it's pretty cool
it's honestly like I think everyone's
missing the excitement at Heathrow
obviously and we were gonna be covering
we're gonna be raising money for direct
relief anyway that was like always the
plan and so it's this great melting of
coz it at e3 we always have like it's
kind of what we do at e3 it's we have
the the game announcements and stuff and
then we have another stage where we get
guests and friends on but it's usually
just a chat we don't actually play get
to play games together
ya know that was a mistake I didn't mean
to do that
and so yeah and then I guess you want to
go there so okay I can do that well I
went the wrong way and so now we're
getting to I did it so now we're getting
to like raise money for charity and play
games with friends who we only really
ever get to see like you know once a
year and it's been it's been really fun
it's like we're doing wide variety of
things like doing quizzes we had we're
getting like the last podcast on the
left guys on to help us solve crimes
next week yeah it's it's been a good
just for me as like a fan just as
something to like know that it's running
during the day and like I pop on and
like have it yeah yeah new one go gamers
hi welcome to the ultimate game of
stream okay oh it's these guys yay
so oh this I remember this
yeah so don't that needs to go and then
it plays here and then I think it needs
to go
oh how do you get there
look oh there's stuff above us so maybe
we drop it oh wait wait this needs to go
like here so if you put the cube right
underneath there okay and then I like
pretty much I appreciate it you what if
I put it in the laser oh yeah see I knew
that was the thing so if you turn it
around so it fires oh where I am oh I
can't kill you right okay
I think well it can kill you
I got okay I'll be right there
oh I have to I forgot I have to like
track through the hole okay alright so
there's the squishier things that I have
to watch out for
yeah very attack of the clones gin ocean
droid factory whoa see okay it almost
hit me again okay why was i standing uh
okay here we go
oh nice essence and then oh I have to
hold it
oh I think so and then now there's a
thing behind you it's going up oh oh
okay okay alright
wait I'm gonna get drilled again I have
to here okay just just hang on and I
won't get hit by those squishers okay so
I yeah but then where do I go
oh wait wait oh no okay so there and
then there okay I know where I have to
go now okay mm-hmm do I have to do you
need a portal for me can I can I assist
in the portaling oh shoot
yes so you need to put one here and here
god your brain goes so much faster than
right oh okay I see got it
I think it's just because while you were
up there I got like I went up on this
lifter and I just waited I just saw
everything I was like oh yeah yeah you
ready yeah okay all right and then I
[Music]
nailed it we did it
oh cool and I lived nice going to more
in the chat says have you tried thinking
with Botox
well now I have you in like this weird
time I guess you're not in the office
anymore working from home yeah we're
we're playing it extra safe yeah working
so New York is kind of opening back up
yeah but you know we'd rather just kind
of since we have the the luxury of being
able to work from home we might as well
still take it and just totally totally
minimize even even if a risk is small
just completely not have that yeah no
that's smart and I mean we're doing the
same California is I don't know doing
better than a lot of states but they're
talking about opening up again and
things are spiking again it's just very
very strange so I've seen
if ya hmm fly up on that thing and hit
the button again and then maybe oh oh I
think so I didn't see whether the wall
was them I will continually launch
myself in the air for you thank you oh
I'm through um but you're not oh you
give me a portal out here but there's no
there's no place to put it in here oh oh
the cube Oh
Hritik and chassés bring the cube and
use the cube to block the door
thank you chat backtracking video I'll
be right there
mm-hmm okay you should hit the oh okay
so if you bring it and like so I need to
portal it over there right or something
I'm trapped in it oh no so bring it
close to the door and then the next time
you train yourself I'll when the doors
open I'll like grab it Oh smart okay
cool let's see
Thank You chat please continue to help
this that's gonna be that's gonna be a
thing oh oh what happened that you got
doored hey I'm all the way back here
okay all right I'm running money I'm
running I'm trying to think if I can
make it so it like I fling it uh I can
technically flowing it anyway oh we can
yes
oh wait wait yeah yeah so put the portal
put the cube there and then put the
portal underneath it
oh yeah
when I'm by the door okay yeah okay got
it okay ready yeah
I feel like a meme I was like snipe okay
well yes that was incredibly satisfying
Wow who knew
Hritik in the jacket JB 44 says Jake
it's time to go big brain
I'm trying me too oh but working from
home has been you know pretty pretty all
right you know at least for content
creation it's yeah it's definitely you
know it's kind of like at least for me
it's like how I started and so it's kind
of like ah back to the old ways like
yeah the grass roots but the tricky
thing is not having as much
collaboration it's so much better when
you have people in the room where you're
like hey do you like this gif of John
Stamos should we put this in the video
you know like when you just have like
other people behind you guiding you and
stuff it really yeah you missed that
sorry strange like trying I mean discord
drinks with people and zoo meetings are
all well and good but it's not the same
as being yeah I just I just almost
killed myself jumping wearily weird
early game is here man yeah we got it
clearly
so where is there cute so oh here's a
okay hmm there's a downstairs I'm gonna
go investigate okay nothing so I'm
assuming something needs to go here and
something needs to go there
Oh cubes QQ cubes oh where are you going
I'll go down there down there yeah okay
let's see this is a lot of stairs this
is like Snake Eater Ladder
okay um there's no cube down here oh wow
but there's a floor for portaling hmm so
there's that so so we need one down here
for some reason I would assume so I can
see the cubes coming down got a
controller sailboat is got to control
the laser hmm okay hmm
let's hmm people in the chat are asking
Gilbert see says Jake ps4 Xbox series X
oh boy isn't that the question of the
day why don't I just quote amazing Dane
DeHaan an amazing spider-man 2 right now
I I still need to see more games from
from Xbox but if we're talking purely
hardware a little bit towards Xbox just
because I like the services and and the
software options and all that stuff all
that fun stuff make it interesting to
talk about and interesting to think
about because I like like I was so
excited for the Nintendo switch because
it like kind of rethought the way we
play games you know it was like oh you
can plug it into your TV you could take
it on the go that was new and exciting
so I feel like all of the stuff Xbox has
been doing they've been trying to make
it a little more interesting and
different so I'm hoping but then again
like PlayStation there's something to be
said about the PlayStation thing last
week they were like it's a console we
got games you play the games by like you
like games yeah and I don't hate that
like that I don't hate that at all
so I through I went through and hit that
button how did you do that oh you okay
so I'm gonna like pop down here what
happens if I hit the button
button deactivated it oh oh it injures
the direction okay so we said oh wait
wait so I got it
so the first one you go here and that
hits the button then you go again but
you go here so if my portals are the
ones to hit the button you do one here
and then that yeah all right okay yeah I
mean for me like I know I'm gonna get
both yeah but the thing that I'm kind of
questioning now is like where am I gonna
play everything because I want to
obviously be where my friends are and
then oh yeah oh wait oh no did you go in
mind
oh if you go in your red one you'll be
able like will catch that one okay so
that's my god so we're supposed to I
guess you would go first right yeah and
then I don't know how long
so you go and I'll pretty much go quote
like soon after you yeah alright cuz I
want to play with my friends are like
and this Jen everyone has pretty much
overwhelming you doing ps4 oh where are
you oh no right I'm all the way I'm in a
special place so one sec let me so I
didn't come there but it did bring me to
a new area okay yeah okay so I think we
got to catch it in midair so let's go
back boom that's not well
I think it's just oh this is what this
is a timing one boy these are the portal
ones that are I mean skill oh god its
timing I don't have that so I don't play
a lot with other people so I can kind of
just bounce around wherever you know
it's kind of nice to like not have a
horse in the race I'm just like ah let's
see what happens they're all cool okay
do unicity was your one up here and then
oh I think I need to adjust mine a
little more okay got to be spot-on okay
so so I think it throws up a couple so
alright sergeant not until you see what
coming through the tube
okay I'm going babe okay come on
oh just oh can I say there's a that's
fine
let me try it again oh no
all right oh okay hang on sir beeps yeah
beeping it knows you you run out of
right time where it's toggled gotcha
okay all right I'm ready once again okay
three two one I'm going what hit the bun
okay I'm gonna get the next one
Oh see you here I can't hear it so hang
on oh that oh the beeping maybe it's
it's like a countdown yeah so it didn't
go that time okay so I think it's just
our first on that one that you got a hit
for okay mmm
all right maybe that beep-beep-beep is
like a 3 2 1 go yeah yeah I think so
okay like you know yeah sure definitely
this is the big brain energy here this
is okay this is only my second coffee of
the day - come on
Oh No okay so I vote earlier in the beep
so basically okay this time we'll get it
I have to I have to do this I am a gamer
like my father before okay
oh that's fine oh [ __ ] wait the timing
okay
so it is independent the blocks shooting
out is independent of when you hit it
yes it took me I only just figured that
now I don't know if I knew that but no
it was a big revelation for me okay
three two one go it's button
Oh
oh come on I was right there ah man
alright alright this is it this one's it
yep let's just go okay
three two one
to
you got it yeah all right well now what
do I do
oh okay I'll be right there I'll bring
the thing so then this I think goes here
and then oh no you can you can just send
it straight down yeah yeah you can just
send me straight to that so I think this
too that you can do you put it in this
you put it in this box first and send it
there oh oh wait so there's a fan Hey
okay and then that fan is that red
lightning okay oh I'm to hold it while
you do something do something oh wait
this uh set oh look out for the Lancer
just trying to bolt it oh wait and then
can I get in there what am I to her one
okay there is no other one
can I get over that oh wait wait wait
what if yay so let me jump here whoo
hello I mean okay so if you know so I
think I need to use the wall and make it
go cuz I there's no way for me to I
don't even hmm I can oh wait what if I
go through here oh okay there's a fan
shut down here so yeah yeah so if you
point it at that wall I must be able to
see that wall oh and then tap a part of
you
yeah so then there's a fan cool down can
you wear can you aim it that I can oh
maybe this wall we haven't used this one
for anything oh I'm trying everything so
I'm like stuck in here oh can you aim it
oh I got hang on put a portal here and
then aim it through that one and it
might come through the window it doesn't
seem like it nope oh maybe maybe put it
like here almost second wall up ah
so a minute yeah trying yeah okay yeah
that was me
oh that oh no that work yeah yeah all
right it up so if you put it back there
and then there's a if you hit tab you
should see
yes what I'm looking at okay wait so
right so put it back to this guy first
like through the window yeah okay
I have no laser though oh no wait waited
the laser go Oh in that case you're fine
I guess we're done here yes wait now I'm
coming back I might I'm lost
yeah I can't Porter you but you've
turned the fan off so if you go to sing
really that I did so hit one there and
then jump off where we were jumping up
earlier yeah
Brandon Hernandez asks do you guys drink
coffee or energy drinks to stay up all
of the above
mostly coffee trying to avoid energy
drinks me too I can't do energy drinks
anymore cuz I just it's too much I saved
them for like special occasion tasks
where I'm like I have so much work time
to open up a can of spinach like Popeye
okay I did it
we're here thank you for bearing with me
I know that was that was really tough I
had forgotten how much fun this one is
though I like I love puzzle solving a
lot I am did you watch that video a
couple weeks ago of the guy doing a
Sudoku puzzle in half an hour but it's
like one of its it was like a movie
it was incredible I would probably get
angry it was very good oh the optional
area over here let's let's see what's
over here oh that's what you oh this is
where you were okay it's this way you
can put the laser I was excited I was
maybe there's a collectible I don't know
my brain is trained okay in this game
mother three two one go
easy oh I went into a wall all I
remember is the ending of this whole
collapse the whole co-op mode is awesome
I didn't even get there you know inside
Jessica again okay there it is oh those
easy
and here's on giant Nintendo Wii all
right that one was suspiciously okay
yeah so that was no that was seven so
next time we need to do eight okay ooh
every time Oh professor moon in the chat
says they want to see fable for and I'm
totally with them on that
oh yeah me too maples like my favorite
game ever or one of them I think about
it all the time
so I'm really hoping that they try again
I wouldn't be Lionhead yeah because it's
who playground master room oh yeah
oh thank you Noah's um if ball has
donated $10 to block my sponsor thank
you so much now has been donating
throughout this whole event that's
really thank you very much and we're
streaming for black lives matter and
Direct Relief links on the screen right
now and this should be the description
to please give what you can for these
great courses Jake and I are gonna
donate money for every level that we
complete and then work is cane we're
gonna match that because corporations
thanks corporations sometimes corpse no
Star Wars Star Trek oh my god don't find
me I said Star Wars instead of Trek Star
Trek yesterday we're doing a really cool
thing while you if you tweeted using
their hash tag they would donate a
dollar what really yeah yeah oh I did
not see that that's cool alright let's
see if we can do another one I think we
can I think we've got this now yeah
we've got we've got a good flow where
basically you're smart and you just tell
me go here and I go okay it's perfect
look I've just covered the ping buttons
so that's it now you're just pointing
everywhere wondering you can you can
tell what kind of apex player I am
because I just highlight everything and
stay out of sight because I'm terrible
wait there's a problem we've done what
we've done this one correct wait a
second wait did we
hello hello did we oh wait hang on
number one did we mess this up yeah
thank you to sailboat for saying you
guys got this
just as we then messed up low didn't
realize we loaded in the boy boy we
can't I'll go to hub we can we can all
that in hick around Oh
tam has just let me know that Jake I
think your mom has donated and I know
$100 Wow
thanks mom thank you so much I don't
know support hears that sometimes
they're slow to show up but thank you so
much and thank you to Matt Hawking who
donated $10 sorry if you talked about
this already but what are you looking
forward to from ei tonight ah
Star Wars yeah I like I like that thing
also I'd love to see Mass Effect
remastered I really I've been putting
playing off - I've been like wanting to
replay - for years and I keep putting it
off so now will be a perfect excuse
oh yeah well what is this a cutscene did
you get that yeah oh okay now with her
we've we've transcended to the next
thing cool
okay we're number three so extra cool
says take place after the main coast
okay
okay uh so wait have we come
enough oh it put us at the beginning are
you here again whatever let's jump in
this thing and see what happens
uh yeah Mass Effect gods Mass Effect
early good yeah I will tell you off
stream about a cool project we worked on
recently but like I'm just kind of
hoping that we do we just kind of like
been sat on it but it was a very cool
interview that we've got to do for audio
logs so like revisiting all the games
I'm like I hope that they announce
anything fun to try and make revisiting
older games interesting from like a
video form okay this is you know we
haven't had terrorists yeah sailboat
says anthem - I know they're still
they're still working on the oh [ __ ]
these turrets are real dude oh okay so I
almost got killed
get you a block so you should be able to
hide from them with this yes you go
David
oh no did that go in the middle oh wait
hang on so oh I need to yeah hang on I
will oh boy oh good shot oh Jesus
uh-huh yeah I need to portal it to me
hang on okay now we're good okay Wow
look at that I'm straight so I think if
I ya go I can just be invincible look at
this
someone said at least be an absolute
shill as a classic film reviewer i'm
ashamed how coolly you write your
reviews I don't write reviews my dude
got him got him
oh that's weird I'm gonna need another
Oh I think it's still passing it to you
okay cool okay so yeah oh boy you should
be able to like tick them over right
like just oh are they behind glass oh I
think no I'm gonna try and I'm trying to
they keep pushing me back Oh
last time I was able to wait what if we
is there a way to launch oh wait there
is any so there's a laser here what can
I do
let me look around here coz there's two
guys oh the two turrets there okay um oh
okay hang on
so where can I put this turret this
laser even that it will kill the turret
there oh oh so you need to shoot it to
me oh wait okay so can you get it
through mmm so you've got if it if the
laser gets to me I can direct it right
into their turret faces yeah so this is
the bridge
[Music]
you gonna look at you they keep shooting
me okay I have a cube
let me just gonna need another one is my
mind is on got him oh I just had to ice
burn them alive okay so let me put that
down that then I just had to burn them
alive so now a cube should be making its
way to you now there you go thank you
and if you could put around the thing
yeah but then I might need how do I get
yeah for you now uh so fit so yeah so
there are turrets right around that
corner I guess you see that do you need
your cube can i all it does is open the
door but oh wait hang on so II uh here
and then let me get another cube and
I'll give you it back in a second I'll
just use it to get these guys can I get
it
no how do i mmm now I'm oh wait hang on
so if that cube opens that door let me
get to your cue okay is there anything
in that next room
I can't access it with the cube it
doesn't open it it like only triggers
part of it uh what does it do
yeah I've given you the bridge back okay
thank you
sailboat says what time is the A's event
so EA's event is at 4:00 p.m. Pt today
so that's 7:00 p.m. Eastern
is that right yes yeah and then we a
GameSpot doing a pre-show at 3:30
shout-out to my friend pink for playing
train valley to lot going on this um so
what did that do that didn't do anything
so I have a camera that's looking at me
hmm but that's it can't do anything so
it's just a camera chat help please
Chuck how can I uh
look out yeah I was trying to see if I
can't go quickly
hmm I think I have to kill them so
trying oh wait wait wait wait wait can
you get them from behind can you go
there and get them through the glass
with the cube graphic you and it's worth
a shot
yeah I don't think so but can you oh
this is like the hammer of dawn this is
it
Oh Lucy so if you just like yeah yeah
yeah I won't go through oh oh wow I
doubted the game and you were right
I could just I could just see it kept
saying like turrets on fire so that I
feel like it's I feel like it's trying
to tell me something fact okay I'm sure
there's much more all right
Oh games very much jaqen DC cyberpunk is
delayed I know
yeah I'm still like catching up on that
news cuz I was I was driving
what like to November yeah they were
super confident when kovat first started
happening and they were like nah our
games still coming out you'll see it
you'll all see I'm honestly not
surprised in a way like I kind of I mean
I'm oh well I was trying something I was
trying something new
uh can you Oh ping that if you like I'm
over the mind of like a delayed game is
eventually good a bad game yes that
forever that kind of thing
so like I don't mind it I mean given how
much the which was delayed yeah and at
the end of it
absolutely ten out of ten game so well
basically guess what calm scale okay so
I think I need to yes I need to see you
know what I have to do is use my brain
so I think here we come through here so
I need a hole okay I have one of those
but you have one okay so um I can't need
to drop oh can you drop it from it drop
some over there so I thought oh wait I
know yeah yeah Shh
this here comes maybe Oh nope nope
so I'm if I'm in this place I can go no
[ __ ] here comes I did it
you just have to portal it on my war end
if you if you are over here see I can
pay ya like so if I if I come through
here oh okay so I portal it there okay
ready yeah get ready and then and then
put it here and then oh yeah you see so
like then what I think we have to do is
o go through here and then you've got to
like come through that blue and put one
here and here okay so oh I have to do it
after it yeah yes while it's in my
domain for lack of a better word want to
get over to you yeah okay let me know
when you're ready okay I'm ready okay
so and here it comes
once it's through over oh wow that was
close
oh this is like this is like oh oh all
my years of netball Oh easy easy okay
Wow starting to feel smart what's she
gonna do though she's saying does any of
us two more talk more [ __ ]
oh we're allowed to go home in this one
wow thanks
[Music]
huh all right not bad that is now three
down I think but we're on eight we
something like that hi toast Emma Costa
said they're new to the stream welcome
we are playing games or playing portal 2
for charity today so playing for black
lives matter and for Direct Relief
donation links are on the screen right
now oh my god okay let me wait for me
wait for GLaDOS to finish Chang but
we've got a couple donations to read out
thank you so much everyone's being so
generous Alessandra filari
games let's raise $100 thank you so much
mate I'm a big fan I was the best I know
anyway he was on that quiz with you oh
yeah thank you so much and yeah if you'd
like to donate links on screen and in
the description right now please give
what you can
okay okay looks like a lot okay so I see
glass thing so glassy laser I see the
thing of that oh listen this is the
[Music]
weird little oh it's like you go in
there so this all right look I'm Marty
making progress look at this
oh yeah so so if I go up here oh look at
that
hello the walking animation is really
fun okay so then we've got a bridge and
then why can I send this to you
I guess right oh no so that I'll leave
it on I need to figure out oh yeah cuz I
can't shoot my portal while that's on
how do we turn this around
oh maybe Hey oh wait no no sorry we get
rid of mine but the put your laser thing
back up here and he lifts that that was
me wait who where so if you Oh God so I
have like a Tron light-cycle thing
blocking my way I can't get rid of that
uh oh
oh I'll cancel at the portal oh we know
that's your portal it's my portal and I
can't get rid of it hang on hang on let
me we can I come back out here I'm I'm
you okay so there and then so I'm going
in here I'm gonna try run go through
huge did I do my thing
yes please
I just assumed just a moment boom how do
i this needs to go this the walkway
needs to go somewhere but I where's the
door Oh is there okay ah
I know I'm complimenting an old game but
I really like being able to see what
you're seeing
yes oh wait hang on bridge can be used
to block Jake and hold him in the
suspension field so you can reposition
and move stuff around ah okay so oh so
you need me to go through you go through
okay but like I don't know if I've done
mine in the right place
oh you need to put your a oh oh I'm in
and I'm in a loop okay I'll do it there
all right one second where dude so this
needs to go this is probably this is not
what I intended I think I mess up
Oh people on the chat are talking about
dead space now which I would be so down
for could it happen I mean I feel like I
don't know I feel like we're like I want
it so bad but I feel like they've really
moved on from that I don't know I don't
want to say that obviously visceral
though you know yeah oh okay wait that's
not what I'm supposed to do dang so this
goes up oh there's a second laser thing
here oh so we need to oh so okay does
that need to go through like here I'm
guessing
I'd say yep that's spot-on okay so you
aim at there let's see
oh okay there's a platform that goes up
here comes okay so wait that just sends
me there how do I get you there oh hang
on um okay I think I need to be holding
the laser in the field if we can direct
it at me when I'm going through it yes
so so we need to get that laser back oh
well technically we can't because one
has to be here doing its thing yeah so I
think that's in the chat says I love
portal Jake is great but this is like
watching two people put together
mission accomplished
yeah so there's this ruse I'm gonna know
it on another cube or now no I don't
think so this one gets me in there so I
need to send the bridge out just
somewhere and I think you need to do the
like so if you set the thing out so I
can get through here and then this
bridge needs to stop you from doing
something so that I can it's not for the
laser because I can't direct the laser
while I'm because the laser is here and
only here oh wait wait okay so the laser
No all right so we're hitting the other
one but
[Music]
how do i alright now I have to like
seriously stop and think you know what
would it be bad if I YouTube this know
it's good for pacing uh portal 2 which
chess chamber is this oh boy um it's
like remember this is only supposed to
take an hour and a half by the way like
the whole thing the whole thing we
imagine us completing it chat if you
have any suggestions please let us know
so oh my god I'm getting like a bunch of
solar panel adverts on YouTube okay
interesting yeah cuz it's like I have to
be holding it in order to
so we did that one wait a minute what if
you put your blue your other portal yeah
over I don't know here you need to put
the cube through the motion stream and
use the bridge to stop it put the cube
through the motion stream yeah and okay
okay so we need to okay so he's in there
I can't do anything cuz I'm blocked off
now oh boy so now I have to achieve okay
it would need to go oh whoa
okay wait now I got it hey Wow
now it seems so easy that was so simple
oh wait no wait no she did not go like
that I don't know um ooh although I
don't know why I'm up here oh because
you would have to so you can't get to
the exit from there right no so it needs
to end with us both okay so yeah there's
got to be something you need to be able
to do up there for me yeah I guess yeah
let me that would be mm-hmm where's that
other blue one
okay wait so what if I send you the cube
is there anything you can do with the
cube in there I may be from there you
can send it elsewhere but if I we would
need to set up my portal before that
because as soon as I'm in here and their
store is closed I can't cross this
threshold and put a portal outside oh
yeah okay okay
hmm what's chasing whompin says big
brain activate the ultimate game is
cheesy I'm gonna message to all let's
say I feel like I'm like right there
or maybe not at all okay
[Music]
it's just 800 yeah I think I'm close
three
maybe use the late the real the real
ralph nader's as maybe use the laser to
open the gate in front of Lucy then she
can put the bridge before the laser and
jump down before it closes oh okay
so so I would need to give you the just
just a moment I'm trying to remember how
to I think a brain fart now okay
so then I just use that as a bridge like
Shh
so you would put the bridge before the
laser so you would put it before the
laser I don't know what he means by
before uh so I can only really put it
like hmm can you put it there well yeah
yeah okay maybe okay that doesn't do
what I thought it was gonna do like lock
the laser is it just so that I can get
out I I guess oh yeah and then move the
laser
oh wait wait and then hang on hang on so
got the laser here but we want to put
the laser so it hits this one right yeah
that is the thing that does the UM that
opens the thing that opens the thing so
we want to block this so block it I'm I
block it
so we want to we want to be over here
and then I just like release the portal
[Music]
sailboats those Pizza sounds really good
right about now
it does I'm so hungry and because all
this brain work is making me starving
dude like not only did we have to hack
the game now we have to really hack the
game we have to solve Gabe's puzzles oh
thank you so much to celebrate for $20
to direct relief Prem Patel is given $20
to black last night - thank you so much
Matt Hawking an additional $10 black guy
was Matt - on top of the $10 he gave -
Darrell you thank you so much if you
have any questions in the chat we have
our best we have time time I don't
understand
I know I it's probably gonna be so
embarrassing anything so iris in recent
oh you know we're definitely
overthinking it because it needs to hmm
okay I'm thinking
it's like go through that
[Music]
let's see I'm no that's wrong
well we can use our hang on
maybe if I know that's not gonna work
all right Tavis typing you might have
what level is this is this like the
third yeah that's the thing I couldn't
watch out for that laser huh okay so how
did we get in here I believe we do
German through here yeah we came in
through here I'm gonna see if I can find
I mean need to see what door like there
must be a puzzle okay
art therapy two of nine two of nine okay
Matthew Hawking fly with the cubes this
fly my fear I don't know I knew that was
like a part of it but I'm trying to
figure out how to like what to do with
the cube so if I ya know there's no cuz
we wouldn't need any reason to be over
there again yeah unless that balcony is
something we're overlooking
seems like chat is kind of stumped as
well looking so I'm glad it's not just
it's not just us mm-hmm sit this one it
also doesn't help that like the names
change all the time to like none of
these seem to be in order
portal 2 ah therapy which is chapter 6
apparently do you wanna just go back to
the hub or do you want to like I want to
I kind of want to finish this let's say
I'm trying to okay we got through the
whole like with no problems until we got
to this particular bit
hmm oh hang on Tam's written okay shall
I phone you yes phone a friend phone a
friend yes please
typing that hours gonna be a nightmare
yeah okay typing that I was gonna be
nice make a portal that the cube to the
laser and stop it with the bridge that's
in the chamber yeah I'm watching it I'm
giving you a live play-by-play thank you
fasting on these happen one of you needs
to take the cube to the platform okay
the traversal to the chamber where
because we're following your
instructions is yes to once you're there
you need to place a pole on the bridge
so that it comes into the room where you
are yeah and then you've got one second
this is great welcome this is what we
did like away at the beginning if you
DoubleTap the screen it should speed
ahead yeah
so then you need to put the laser
through the yellow pole still hmm
so the laser needs to call us and it
needs to be a red pole on the right hand
side so of the long strip right side
view so parallel to the blue pole where
it currently is there should be a red
port then the lasers go go through it so
it's the second switch right oh is it am
I in the right place I don't think so I
think he means here yes oh yeah okay
okay got it
go to the second staircase so there's a
yellow pole on the little square okay
and then you put the cube through there
that comes out he was moving okay I
think I put up an athlete there I can't
follow directions use the platform to go
up and then it should carry the cube
along the bridge in the middle and stop
right in front of the second switch to
get one thing okay yeah okay I need you
[Music]
to get the cube into
one of the suspension beams and then
have the laser and direct into the
second switch okay I see I just have to
angle it bridge once it's through oh I
can't I can't fire it out again I think
mine is in the wrong place
yeah my mind should be here but like I
can't get it
so close you the laser again and then I
can so I'm doing something wrong -
because mine only temporarily hits it so
it needs to be blocked right yes I think
if you do the laser thing like we've
been doing it i put my thing there
yay amazing so send it to you like how I
would at the start yeah
so if you put yours there and then if
you're unlucky in this case yep one
second and then I do that and then you
send it through like we've been doing it
it's not okay yeah so what it should
look like is on the second switch it
should be a suspension bridge there and
then when the cube comes through it hits
the laser and reflects it into the
second switch yeah got it
so then I think okay so when we leave
that oh wait it got rid of my thing oh
my god up so no so I need to I need to
exit through this I don't know okay got
it got it got it
it took us literally half an hour I can
tell I'm gonna not really sorry don't
know we're gonna start over or you you
need to need to do the the laser thing
again I know the wrong way
so then I need to put mine here then I
need to exit through here brilliant ok
you yeah time I'm gonna keep you on the
line as we as we finally do this okay
all right
feel like you've been a part of this
journey yeah thank you
oh my god do you remember how like maybe
45 minutes ago we were saying you feel
so small we do do you want to do some
community Maps yeah let's try your stuff
- oh that's extreme okay thank you to
everyone who's been tuning in and who's
in the chat trying to help us out this
is I don't we had so many games we were
trying to like pick to play yeah
and then we were like yeah portal is a
good idea we gave them loves pool yeah
okay go to hub or is it hub try are
there any in particular that are very
very good Charlie I would love to hear
from ya it might have to I don't think I
can access them from here maybe I exist
to main menu let's see it says community
test chambers like hi that's my okay so
I get to browse the workshop uh
attack cooperative slope I'm most
popular
gels and lasers
what's the I'm gonna go for the most
popular ones of all time yeah that's a
good idea so I don't know if there's any
way to check how difficult they are I
hope you have fun who's saying I hope
you have fun was I this is the
description on one of the maps ah the
order of things full if you have
suggestions here we estimated difficulty
ah mean easy / medium that sounds that
sounds good
okay so I think I have it in my game now
this is team Mike - and then if
occurrence and then you should have had
the in May so they invited you a waiting
invite aha perfect okay love when things
work I've never done any of the custom
ones in here uh in Portal 2
I guess cuz I played it on when I played
it on PC but then I played it the coop
on ps3 I think
oh but that was cross-platform I think
with me hello okay this is we should
have played army of two we should have
played I'm hiring a high-five button
I remember go to a press event farm you
have two back in the day
really yeah the first one no food I
think it was Devil's cartel okay it was
the same the same press event where I
saw Mass Effect threes
yeah was it the citadel dlc was it and
Dead Space 3 was there don't this map
was created by doctor foul she was that
wow factor okay so we need things are
going and find the cube I think we need
to go figure out how to turn this bridge
off that's possible okay I see the cube
let's do this this makes me go up uh-oh
there's a bridge oh this is cute okay I
love that there's no portal walls oh
there is kind of one no there isn't
behind glass hmm oh hang on there is a
there's a jumpy spring thing down there
yeah so I figure out how to turn the
bridge off mm-hmm this one if I go in
this evil orange death ray should I go
in this it's the color of me yes it's
done okay here we go
I think you just stay there
no oh cool cool cool flips
oh okay so Jeevan for that yeah all
right
oh wait hang on so oh okay look so I've
put a bridge here this is gonna be
horrible oh but they put a mesh over it
so I can't get in there should I leave
oh okay okay hang on I think so
oh I ok so hello I'm here okay and then
I do so how do I get up mm-hmm
this is really tricky when there's you
can't go through the portals okay oh
hang on
so this can go stuff here this can go oh
oh yeah that stuff everywhere so you can
you go through that I can't go through
it it's like got a limit to it so maybe
actually this one but it makes you go in
one direction
try um-hmm so the bridge goes up the
this must fling you up there yeah swing
me into the beam
ooh okay okay yeah so I can do this
and then oh wait and then can I do yeah
Wow okay look at that oh so I think your
sacrifice I think when I'm doing that if
you send the Lightbridge my way okay
does that work
compounding how can I do that so I think
if I do this and then I go yeah so you
can get that bridge by putting it like
one here and then one over there okay
one here and one and then you should be
able to hit here this one and that
should make a bridge for me oh oh okay
oh I got a cube
I got a companion cube okay
so I gotta get you back there's a lot of
lasers there wait can I get the gay
panic you know it's behind glass okay
that's a lie umm just like the cake I
guess so I wasn't gonna make that okay
uh okay so then wait a minute what if I
what if you boy mom no I think I got it
do i I have to go
if I go through there I'll go through
the lasers I have to go under so that's
okay so maybe we can drop okay so if you
if you drop the do you have to come here
with me I think you have to come here
with me I might not just because there's
other things that can get me up there
over here if you follow I think yeah if
you come through here and then oh no oh
okay how did I get up here
oh wait wait and then that was close
yeah yeah I did the same one and then if
you come through here and then what I
think you do is you put your red one or
is it so there's this one that takes you
Joe oh no you put your red one there
sorry so if you put that there
then you make you make a bridge okay
okay yeah so then under here can I get
and none we raise it oh wait so yeah so
I'm up here ah we make a bridge here I
mean this one I don't think so no that's
still laser level so look the laser with
the bridge lock the laser with the
bridge no I think what so you go let me
bring it back down to the other one hang
on oh boy
okay so
okay so now you go and cry oh now we got
to get you back over here oh I think I'm
just gonna kill myself
yeah so we're on the same so I hope you
you go and then I go right oh yeah
you've got the if you put your own thing
to the bridge yeah I don't remember
oh one pins it's okay we're all just
we'll just getting through this together
got okay so then I this which holds or
is this for me is it the light blue one
yeah oh wait where are you oh it's okay
I can still get you up here yes okay
hello thank you oh boy yeah yeah so I
don't think we can block that no so what
we need to do right is drop it down and
then you walk to the other side of it
and then we bring it up
oh no technically that would yeah I
don't like an elevator oh I thought I
thought I figured it out ah mmm wait so
then this gets us up there I guess
and then hmm how is this easy to medium
oh there's no yeah there's no way to
portal over there oh wait what happened
to the cube the keeps moving what what
move oh did it get pushed by the thing
hello
look can you see my screen yeah I talked
to some what started it moving um I
guess just maybe there yeah it was okay
okay let's do so basically you would
need to drop it before it hits the laser
and have it fall down to the lower
bridge and have the other person jumped
out and catch it
maybe yes that is correct okay right we
know how to do this
he know my cat stop go away no I want to
see the cat the cab is chewing on my
Leon Kennedy statue don't do that oh no
don't do that yeah okay I got you I have
to come with you know you just go first
right oh yeah I think yeah I know it
works oh okay yeah so one pins you're
pulling it towards you that's right and
then we can I like drop it so shout out
the wipers thanks dude oh I just I'm
gonna die you good okay thank you for
the confidence we've been through a lot
we have been through a lot this is like
war so if you put your the yellow one
right yes the yellow one what and then I
go through and is it the dark blue I
need to do ah yes dark blue oh oh oh no
I walked backwards alright so we just
okay so we just rinse and repeat like
you can you stay then yeah you can I
like just taking myself out of the
equation Tandi yes cyberpunk really is
delayed until November if we were
talking about that and then we got
really into not being smart
yeah it's I'm honestly like fine with it
and yeah I was probably gonna play it on
next-gen anyway so I mean I was
definitely and if that means that I had
this less of a wait like if I was gonna
be playing it in September when the
consoles weren't out until who knows
November that would be weird and I don't
I don't know it's not maybe the ideal
way to plan as the outcross save which
would be cool but who knows
I know it's smart delivery but
and the game will be better ideally I
mean I do phim is pretty limited but I
do feel like that's much harder to do
when everybody is working from home
especially like a large-scale game like
that 2012 should have been the
apocalypse what a youtube name they said
is it is it considered satanic if I say
I never played any of the pool games hmm
satanic I'm missing out I do remember
when the first one came out it was just
like what is this like it came out of
nowhere
yeah whomping says I strongly energy to
fight immediately and I completely agree
so you put your bridge okay I'm gonna
walk forward and so then is this my it's
my dark blue goes here okay so I wasn't
quick okay you just need to shut it off
I need I need to stand here and do it so
[Music]
okay I need to do it quicker is it
moving
I can't so I can't so I'll tell you I'll
tell you when it's I'll tell you when to
do it now hey now we got to get this
thing back up here and you put your
bridge and we walk along that right yeah
yeah okay so then oh [ __ ] I think I used
the wrong portal Oh No
I ruined it I blew it I blew it no it's
fine you are thinking the portals I'll
just stay here I'll die and leave you
floating um and then you just go and get
the bridge yep you suck you were raised
better than that
I think about like the right thing in it
is so good and it's still so sharp and
funny even you know
Gotham is at 2007 the first one came out
so I think you just need to put your
yellow portal here and that'll make the
bridge from me so if you go back to the
female
oh okay I knew I'll do it again yeah
yeah I got you
I'll just stand by know the writing and
the humor and even like the little bits
of world-building they did here are just
very I guess timeless like the way the
humor works and stuff it's very like
simple but really really good I thought
your game is so simple but clean
yeah becoming do that get like a teapot
surfer dude what what is the game you're
most looking forward to for the rest of
the year mmm oh so the rest of the year
Resident Evil 8 is 20 21 I believe yeah
so it's it's cyberpunk and do we have a
date for vampire the masquerade yeah no
I think it is 2020 because that is that
is up there for me okay so what do I
need to do I can't we just need to put
one here yeah and that would be gives me
a bridge and then bingo
Oh oh my god no okay okay let's do it
all over again I'm so sorry
it's fine we know exactly what did you
know this is gonna be so quick oh yeah
so efficient and effective yeah
Oh God okay portal other portal okay and
then I will give you the thing thank you
you think Oh Matthew how can i just just
don't drop the cube and he was like I
know I'm sorry okay I'm over here and we
dropped down yeah bridge and then I'll
spot you again dark hit it no sorry
so hit it nice oh now we go back up and
then I will bring us one things to say
I'm so invested in this journey are you
gonna be able to make that uh you might
have to go first cuz you're a better me
there we go okay so there I think your
bridge needs to do it because if I do
mind it'll just suck us towards that
instead of okay ready yeah
Oh every landing is my god it's okay
alright but oh now we have a now we have
a portal over here so we can do stuff
okay what I have no idea oh I know do
the thing so we can there we go now we
go up oh wait no wait wait that just
sends us so we need a bridge too so if
you can grab the bridge yeah yeah and
then Brigid there no I can't I can't
bridge here
hmm maybe I go up in it I can oh okay
well can you shoot it yeah okay okay and
then if you go over there yeah so I'll
jump and then you hit it cuz I have to
like now fall oh yeah I'll come to you
so Maureen - one jump and then good so
yeah three two one
Wow hello look at this huh okay
it seems harmless so okay
hmm oh wait wait what
so we can get in here what's in here oh
no jeez more okay so the problem is that
we lost the cube the cube fell this this
cube is still here
so wait okay so my right click and so
you can still get we can still get it in
over here right so look here's the
bridge okay and then I can even you yeah
I can even do of this lorry sorry no
really what do I do now it's fine cuz
it's fine because like yeah we're okay
Oh relax GLaDOS I need to thank you oh I
did an opposite until I canceled allowed
my
okay so this is red that means this is
yellow right here oh okay I'm on the
bridge ready when you are
you need to come over here right oh yeah
dah
three two one jump excellent okay so
it's my okay so I have a yellow so mine
is I can do this so you can you can pull
us onto that yeah Oh No
ah okay we've got like full minutes left
at this dream juice we're gonna do it
I can oh you can put it up here so do I
have to die too and come back thank you
wait I could do it from here okay
so you get there oh yeah look at that oh
wow
he need to jump at work oh good wait so
we didn't even look in here but oh
there's a hole oh my god this is just
where the cube came from we could have
just done this okay alright alright so
we're not gonna die this time
no you're going left right okay
made it
so if you move yours tell like up yeah
that work it's not portable oh wait I
can do no that's not gonna do anything
but it means I can get through here
no it's not mmm
I'm stumped me too
after all of that progress we tried
we're gonna have to wrap it up soon
anyway cuz it's two minutes to two but
thank you so much everyone for joining
us and if everyone who's been donating
we've got a couple more that I'll read
out nice I'm sorry that we're not well
we had like one elite gaming moment I
think I think we did better than I
thought
uh yeah me too especially you have like
the not a very good partner I try be
great
you've been great cuz like you're just
easy to talk to and so I think we found
some good solutions together so let me
look at the tilt fight so if you go to
bit ly / GS - Cove it you can donate to
direct relief anonymous gave 250 dollars
thank you so much good luck with the
rest of the event from your friends at
triple points thank you so much huge
donation and a couple more for black
lives matter so we have $100 from Auslan
Raman thank you so much that's
incredible and another two hundred and
fifty dollars from Queen Weidman thank
you so much uh yeah that's in Christ
Thank You own up yeah thank you so much
everyone
I hope you had fun in the chat sail boat
thank you for your support
womp ins - epic gaming medals to both of
you thank you so much Jake it's been
such a pleasure just chatting to you
even though like portal is one of those
games were like you saw a conversation
and then you have to actually like
activate some real puzzle solving frame
you learned a lesson with
choosing-choosing this game definitely
maybe maybe next time the the idea we
had maybe we can do it I think that
could be good yes they told us I mean I
loved that idea but it's just I think
well but we wanted to play Tony Hawk
basically but it's just not easy to get
Tony Hawk games like at least the new
the older ones in this day and age bar
they are remaking 110 times pro skater
so next time we'll do
we'll deal with that that'll be great
make sure to check back tomorrow from a
play for all we are gonna be streaming
with the voice of Claude Jose Eva from
Fire Emblem three houses and he has a
great segment called Dear Abby where he
gives relationship advice because
obviously in Fire Emblem he's in the
golden deer so deer dwar and the hot all
right yeah he was he was the he was my
boy cuz I was golden deer so we're gonna
give relationship advice and he's gonna
talk us through what it's like being a
voice actor he's gonna give Callie and I
some tips which is wait cuz like my
voice my accent goes between American in
English so I need someone to train me
Jake awaken people find you Twitter and
Instagram at Jake Valley know you can
find me working every day with a bunch
of other great people on the game ranks
YouTube channel and at night sometimes I
post some videos here and there once a
week on youtube.com slash Jake badly
know and I guess you're gonna be joining
joining all of us and playing Last of Us
this weekend - yes
I can't wait I'll do it all right Thank
You Jake
so much again thank you to everyone in a
chair he's been donating we'll see you
again tomorrow
you
[Music]
[Music]